We'll now make a strange and
counterintuitive step.
You know that human chromosomes are linear.
But we want to think about them as
circular, cyclic chromosomes.
Well, why would we do this?
Why would we distort the biological
reality?
The only reason is that it will make our
algorithmic problem much simpler
while actually hardly affecting our
biological conclusion.
Remember, I told you that analyzing
rearrangements in linear chromosomes is
extremely difficult, even if we're dealing
with a unichromosomal genome.
Analyzing rearrangements in
multichromosomal
linear genomes becomes nearly impossible.
And, surprisingly enough, analyzing
rearrangements in multichromosomal
genomes with cyclic chromosomes will turn
out quite simple, we are about the
discover it.
So now we will look at the cyclic genomes.
In this case, cyclic genome, a genome with
a circle
chromosome of consisting of two
chromosomes, and we will arrange blocks
in these chromosomes as directed black
edges.
For example, +a, -b, -d, +c
will be arranged as four edges
with corresponding orientation of these
edges along the circle.
It's just a start.
We will now add to these black edges
undirected red edges that connect
adjacent synteny blocks.
So the two chromosomal
genome will be represented as a graph
consisting of
two cycles.
These cycles, important, they have
edges of two colors, red and black.
Now what
do we do next?
First, let's notice that for every
genome there are many different ways to
visualize it.
For example this is genome Q arranged in
natural order along the cycle, but we can
change arrangements of black edges of Q,
and how in this case this cycle looks like.
Well, after +a, we should go to -b.
That's what we do.
After -b,
you should go to -d, that's what we do.
And after -d, we should go to +c,
and finally to +a.
This is, this is the same genome and the
same graph in fact, the same cycle, just
visualized differently.
Now let's try to figure out how a reversal
looks like in terms of these graphs.
So, we start with genome P:
+a -b -c +d,
and let's make a reversal
on this genome, resulting with
+a -b -d and +c.
How this new genome Q will look like in
the terms of our graph model.
Well, after +a we should go to -b,
after -b we should go to -d
after -d we should go to +c
and finally from +c we should go to +a
So, therefore a transformation of genome P
into genome Q corresponds also to
transformations of the graph shown here.
And how can we summarize what this
transformation does.
Certainly it removes these
two red edges.
And it adds two new red edges.
So in summary, a reversal essentially now
has geometric interpretation.
It deletes two red edges and replaces them
by two other red edges on the same
four nodes.
Now, let's now talk about fission,
breaking a single chromosome into two.
In this case, a unichromosomal
genome P is broken into a genome with two
chromosomes: the genome Q.
So how does it look like in terms of our
graph?
So for, from +a, we should go to -b
and from -b, we should go to +a,
so it will look like this.
And also from -c
we should go to +d
and from d we should go to c.
So you see that geometrically also a
single cycle is broken into two cycles.
What does it mean geometrically again?
Once again, we remove two red edges and
add two new red edges.
And similarly,
in the case of fusion, the reverse
operation, we would
also remove two red edges and add two new
red edges.
And therefore, we define the notion of
"2-break", a rearrangement that replaces
two red edges with two new red edges on
the same four nodes.
What we have just accomplished, instead of
four different operations,
reversals, translocations, fusions and
fissions,
we have a single operation, a 2-break.
I describe how to model reversals,
fusions, and fissions as 2-breaks.
What about translocations.
It's the same story.
Here are two linear chromosomes that after
translocations transform into a blue
chromosome and a green chromosome
shown here.
Once again we represent them as black-red
paths.
Let's circularize them by just gluing the
ends using one of the red edges.
And after we circularize them, let's
perform this 2-break.
We'll choose these two edges.
We'll remove them and substitute
them by other two red edges.
And afterwards, we will simply remove the
edges that we used
for circularization, like here, which
is essentially linearization of circular
chromosomes.
So if you look at this, then you
see that we essentially mimic
translocations using our graphs.
And we will define 2-break distance as the
minimum number
of 2-breaks transforming one genome into
another.
And 2-break distance problem:
input two genomes on the same set
of synteny blocks, and output the 2-break
distance between these genomes.
It's now time to solve this problem.
But before we do this, we need to
introduce the key notion in studies of
genome rearrangements which is called
the breakpoint graphs.